bienvenue sur tv soixante dix huit pour
ce nouveau rendez vous ça s'est passé
chaque semaine nous allons ouvrir les
archives de notre chaîne pour découvrir
redécouvrir quelques-uns des sujets qui
ont marqué l'actualité locale pour ce
premier numéro de septembre
là nous partons tout d'abord en 1999 et
un certain jamel debbouze fait parler de
lui alors en pleine ascension
l'humoriste originaire de trappes décide
de faire un beau cadeau à celui qui l'a
fait monter sur les planches après
l'avoir repéré lors d'un atelier au
collège gustave-courbet alain degois dit
papy est jamel debbouze entend récolter
des fonds pour son association à déclic
théâtre il invite de nombreuses
personnalités pour un spectacle unique
au bataclan nous étions présents
je vous laisse voir cette séquence je
viens faire mon spectacle tranquillement
gentiment je ne me rappelle plus ce soir
non
et l'association en question c'était des
petits théâtres le bataclan à paris a
été pris d'assaut hier soir pour la
soirée exceptionnelle en faveur du
projet de la marmite imaginé par
l'association basé à elancourt jamel
debbouze toujours fidèle à ses racines a
su fédérer autour de lui les artistes
comiques du moment des copains venus
gracieusement par solidarité envers un
projet culturel qui devrait notamment
permettre à la compagnie de recentrer
toutes ses activités en un seul lieu à
trappes et d'accroître les formations
d'improvisation dieudonné gad elmaleh
eric et ramzy pierre palmade djamel s'en
sont donné à coeur joie durant près de
trois heures les sentiments c'est c'est
ça c'est c'est ce retour
ce retour
djamen par rapport à huy gien attrapa à
50 ans et tout ça donc c'est super quoi
le sentiment de ne pas avoir bossé pour
rien depuis dix ans quoi aussi que ce
qu'on peut continuer et que jen encore
une fois nous dit m'a lâché pas les
gains et continuer quoi c'est vraiment
un nouvel élan qu'il qu'areva nouvel an
on a envie de dire des nouvelles choses
des choses qu'on n'a jamais pu dire
avant et la scène par la bcc comique on
va le faire on va le dire le public
composé en grande partie de jeunes venus
de saint quentin mais aussi de toute la
région parisienne n'a pas hésité à
suivre djamel pour aider déclic théâtre
bilan de l'opération près de 200 mille
francs récoltés pour la marmite
ce qu'est baird
la salle était vraiment comblé et je
pense que c'est une très bonne opération
il ya une vraie intention heureuse de
fait rire tous les gens sont venus pour
ça et on s'est bien marré et en plus il
y avait ce pesce d'émotion de solidarité
c'est bien c'est toujours bien ça c'est
un pote qui en écrit ensemble au
scénario donc je vais le voir je connais
la plupart des gens qui étaient là je
les aime bien
je suis venu avec plaisir pour ces gens
là toi demain dans notre pass culture
nous reviendrons sur cette soirée avec
de larges extraits du spectacle de
septembre 99 nous passons maintenant à
septembre à 2005 cette année là la
rentrée de plaisir et marquer par le
chantier du théâtre espace coluche la
salle fait peau neuve et affirme à sa
vocation à recevoir des artistes de
renommée est là aussi nous avons
retrouvé les images
l'ensemble avait 13 ans au total
mais été conçu sur un signe de salle
polyvalente c'est à dire à la fois des
difficultés pour le sport et des
difficultés pour les spectacles l'espace
coluche première version a donc vécu et
c'est un complexe culturel que
découvriront les spectateurs d'ici
quelques mois actuellement on est dans
l'ancienne salle polyvalente qui servait
à la fois pour le sport et le spectacle
qui sera dorénavant uniquement une salle
de spectacle donc dans les travaux
principaux on va avoir un profil de
gradins continuer de façon à ce que tout
le monde une belle visibilité sur la
scène
donc là on essayait de faire des zones y
aura une zone pour le public toute la
partie gauche de la salle qu'on appelle
le jardin sera pour les zones techniques
de livraison de changement de matériel
avec des grands couloirs d'accès tout de
façon que toutes les manipulations soit
facile et rapide et puis toute la partie
cours pour les comédiens à la fois
silencieuse un peu confortable outre la
grande salle de spectacle qui offrira
jusqu'à 900 places assises le projet
prévoit l'arrivée du conservatoire de
danse et de la clé des champs qui se
voit doté de deux studios de répétition
et d'une petite salle de concert c'est
un projet qui coûte 6 millions 4 euros
qui est pas une somme astronomique on a
fait un travail très très pointues pour
à la fois avoir une très grande qualité
de prestations au niveau du confort je
le dis toujours on a on a privilégié le
confort des artistes mais aussi du
personnel est également effectivement du
public bien avant toute chose fin des
travaux en mai 2006 pour une ouverture
au public dès septembre
et c'est ainsi que nous refermons ce
premier rendez vous ça s'est passé
revient la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau voyage dans le temps pour
redécouvrir les événements qui ont
marqué l'histoire locale
[Musique]